Should cancer patients be taking perfect meadows. I
Can't remember off the top of a head, but I think I've looked up
Perfect meadows for other people and I didn't see a problem. I didn't see that they were really high in
glutamine
I know there's a lot of fat supplements out there
So a lot of people will see things on Instagram and Facebook and oh this is the cure-all supplement
I should get that too. I must be just missing, you know, I've just won the supplement shy of perfect health
And you know it can be careful of those things. So protein powders that are high in glutamine
I'm not a fan of you know
Amino acid. What is it amino acid? It is glutamine as is it amino acid?
So is is it high in glutamine if it is that I would say no, you have to look at the label of that
That's why we use the protein design for the USM them because it's a lower glutamine
Protein powder if you're gonna take a protein powder